và phát triển vợ trên sự kết thật của mời loại thảo dưới thiên nhìn
từng cao là khôi hồ sâm chẻ dây mong có mạnh chẻ nông,
ốc ta có đề đều là những tình phân quên thuộc trong độ biệt
có thấp dục hỗ trợ bảo vệ nghiêm mặt sạch dưới,
sạm át sĩ vị và hỗ trợ sạm viên tờ lưu biệt lưu sạch dưới
đã chẳng nhé vệ sẵn tân phù hột bệnh nhau đổi trường
đổi trường xin bị đầy hơi ớt chua khó tiêu,
đưa hiệng hồ dưới sử biệt,
hồ thường xin khẳng thường xin khẳng thằng mời ra
bình bị quan được tiếp kẻ sạch hồ nhau gót tị lời
có thể mang theo bên mình bà sử dục bất cứ lúc nào
em xung cũng sát đơn tàn chỉ cần ngay hơi lần
sáng chứ bự ăn và tụi chức khi đi ngủ
bà sẽ cảm đẹp gió sức khi đổi tiếp tục
không chỉ là một sản phẩm bỗ trợ bảo vệ xe quên
bình bị quan có bán đề xức ăn tâm trong tựa bữa ăn giác mù
xe kí giả dưới đường xam sốc tốt bà sẽ có tìm nâng lựa
để tận hồn cũng không chọn phải hơn